REFERENCING REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA.
>> LET'S BRING IN FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JAMES CLAPPER.
HI THERE.
SO LET'S FIRST GET YOUR REACTION
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN CANNOT REMAIN IN
POWER.
>> WELL, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WAS BEING PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE WAS SAYING OUT LOUD WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY WOULD
HOPE FOR, AND I THINK I KNOW HIM
WELL ENOUGH FROM MY EXPOSURE
WITH HIM WHEN HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT THAT I THINK HE HAD
SEEN -- VISITED WITH SOME
UKRAINIAN REFUGEES, AND I THINK
THAT PROBABLY AFFECTED HIM
EMOTIONALLY.
AND I THINK THAT STATEMENT JUST
CAME OUT BECAUSE I THINK HE
BELIEVES IT.
I DON'T THINK PUTIN WILL BE VERY
SURPRISED BY IT.
THERE'S NO LOVE LOST BETWEEN THE
TWO OF THEM PERSONALLY ANYWAY.
SO I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN CAN
COUNT ON NOT GETTING A CHRISTMAS
CARD FROM PRESIDENT PUTIN.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S SAFE TO
SAY AFTER HE'S ALSO CALLED HIM,
YOU KNOW, A BUTCHER AND ALL
KINDS OF OTHER PERSONAL INSULTS,
A WAR CRIMINAL, AND SO FORTH.
BUT I WANTED TO HIT ON SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAID.
YOU SAID THIS IS WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD ARE
PROBABLY THINKING, THAT PUTIN
SHOULDN'T REMAIN IN POWER.
BUT IF YOU WOULD JUST EXPLAIN TO
OUR VIEWERS WHAT THE CONCERN
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD HAVE
BEEN, WHY THE WHITE HOUSE
THOUGHT IT WAS SO IMPORTANT TO
CLEAN UP THOSE COMMENTS, TO SAY,
OH, HE WASN'T TALKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, PUTIN'S POWER IN RUSSIA.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HIS POWER
OVER NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
JUST WHY WAS THAT SO IMPORTANT
TO DO?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE,
PAMELA.
I THINK THAT PERHAPS A LEGAL
NICETY TO ATTEND TO AND, YOU
KNOW, HOLDING OUT SOME HOPE THAT
PUTIN WILL SOMEHOW AGREE TO
MEANING NEGOTIATIONS, WHICH I
THINK IS, YOU KNOW, PERSONALLY
IT'S A LOST CAUSE, BUT YOU HAVE
TO HOPE FOR DIPLOMACY.
IT REALLY DIDN'T BOTHER ME THAT
MUCH.
WITNESSING THE CRIMINAL, WANTON,
MINDLESS KILLING AND DESTRUCTION
IN UKRAINE, TO ME, IT'S JUST
LOGICAL THAT WE NEED TO GET RID
OF THIS GUY.
AND I THINK ACTUALLY, THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE -- HIS
INTENDED AUDIENCE MAY WELL HAVE
BEEN THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE TO THE
EXTENT THAT WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID COULD GET THROUGH TO THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO I KIND OF THINK THAT WAS
THE REAL AUDIENCE, AND I THOUGHT
THE STATEMENT FROM THE RUSSIAN
KREMLIN SPOKESMAN, YOU KNOW, WAS
PRETTY TEMPERATE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THIS IS A DECISION OF THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, IT WAS NOT AS FORCEFUL
OR FIERY AS ONE MAY HAVE
EXPECTED FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
SPOKESPERSON IN RUSSIA.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
I INTERVIEWED THE CHIEF CYBER
DEFENSE OFFICIAL IN THE U.S. WHO
WARNED THAT RUSSIA COULD SOON
LAUNCH DISRUPTIVE OR DESTRUCTIVE
CYBERATTACKS BASED ON
INTELLIGENCE THAT U.S. OFFICIALS
HAVE.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE MOMENT
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR TO STRIKE THE U.S. HARD ON
THE CYBER FRONT?
IS THAT A CONCERN FOR YOU?
>> WELL, IT HAS BEEN FROM THE
OUTSET.
IN FACT, TO BE HONEST, IT'S BEEN
KIND OF A MYSTERY TO ME WHY THE
RUSSIANS HAVEN'T BEEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH CYBERATTACKS
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES.
AND I WOULD GUESS THAT THE BASIS
FOR THE WARNING, WHICH IS VERY
APPROPRIATE, PROBABLY IS THAT
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN DETECTED
RECONNOITERING CERTAIN NETWORKS,
AND THAT OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE AN
INDICATOR THAT THEY ARE
CONTEMPLATING DOING SOMETHING
WHICH COULD BE AN ATTACK.
SO THE WARNING'S APPROPRIATE,
BUT, AGAIN, IT'S SOMEWHAT
SURPRISING TO ME THEY HAVEN'T
DONE SOMETHING ALREADY.
>> YEAH, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
THEORIES FOR WHY THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET, BUT NO ONE CAN SAY
FOR SURE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS,
THE PRESIDENT WARNING PUTIN NOT
TO MOVE WITHIN A SINGLE INCH OF
NATO TERRITORY.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU THAT THIS
COULD SPILL OVER INTO A NATO
COUNTRY, EITHER INTENTIONALLY OR
BY ACCIDENT?
>> WELL, THAT'S BEEN MY CONCERN
FROM THE GET-GO.
GIVEN THE POTENTIAL FOR A LONG
ROUND OR A SHORT ROUND OR SOME
UNINTENTIONAL, SAY, MISSILE
ATTACK OR MISSILE THAT LANDS
INADVERTENTLY IN A NATO STATE.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, THEN THE
TEST WILL BE LIVING UP TO THOSE
WORDS.
YOU KNOW, NOT ONE INCH OF NATO
TERRITORY BE COMPROMISED.
BUT I DO -- I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND THIS RECENT ATTACK
AGAINST THE OIL DEPOT IN LVIV IS
A CASE IN POINT.
LVIV IS, AS YOU KNOW, PRETTY
CLOSE TO THE POLISH BORDER.
>> YEAH.